I'm welcome to color on air like
webinars from Google cloud we're hosting
webinars every Tuesday
my name is Finn Liu and I'm a software
engineer at Google today I'll be talking
about a clock composer you can answer
questions anytime on a platform and we
have Google Earth on standby to answer
them now let's get started so today I
planned a couple of following topics I
will start by giving an overview of
composer next we'll talk about how to
use composer
followed by a demo and I'll wrap up my
tag with pointers on how to get you
started
so before we start like what's clock
composer what kind of problems are we
trying to solve here in many cases we
find an ease to run something around a
task or branch certain operations at a
predefined interval or in response to an
actual input that we don't we not only
find that in our work place that
sometimes you may it happens in your
life as well it's just the case that you
don't realize that for example like you
know you may have alarm that wakes you
up you know every day at 8 a.m. or you
may want to send an email every Thursday
night so for a task as simple as that
you know cron which is an X it's a
utility in Nick's operating system might
be sufficient for you need sometimes
when you touch the gas a little bit
complicated for example you know you may
have a few tasks and there are some
dependencies among those tasks in this
slide I have an example in the middle
imagine that you have Google App Engine
application which is constantly dumping
logs into the Google Cloud Storage
bucket and every once a while you want
to run a dataflow job that process and
clean up those logs and save them to
bigquery so that you can run useful
metrics useful analytics form the user
data even a task where a workflow as
simple as what I just described if you
think about how you want to implement
math is actually a lot of work you know
you need to make sure you you understand
the API to talk to the various class
services you need to make sure you have
the right author authorization and and
account in place and not even to mention
that you have to worry about failures
they could be service fee news network
failures so at the end of the day you
realize that you spend a lot of time not
actually focusing on your workflow but
rather and all the infrastructures that
runs your workflow I probably will not
even attempt to try to use cron to run
actual machine learning pipeline that's
just too complicated so we believe that
it should be easy to create schedule and
monitor workflows that work inside and
outside of a Google cloud platform with
that mission in mind we introduced cloud
composed of service in a nutshell clock
composer is really a managed Apache
outflow service that makes workflow
creation management powerful consistent
and easy for you we start the clock
composer project with a number of
product goes in your mind we wanted to
have a comprehensive integration with a
lot of cloud services so like I
mentioned earlier as a workflow author
oracular user you don't want you don't
have to worry about talking to the
various cloud services so we do want to
provide high level abstractions so that
makes easy for you to start using other
cloud services we also don't want to
limit in your workflow to GCP tasks only
we want it to be the case that is as
easy as just speed as easy as for you to
start jobs elsewhere for example in
another cloud provider where you are on
prime as studying a job in Google cloud
platform we want to make it a workflow
specification or the definition of the
workflow easy for you as well so hence
we choose the popular and easy to use
language Python for your
right your workflow definition and
finally we want to have open source in a
core F cloud composer so that you know
your workflow is agnostic to where it
gets executed
you can transparently move your workflow
from GCP to amp RAM to another cloud
provider so next I'm going to talk about
some of the key features as well as some
of the design decisions we have made to
fulfill the product goes I just
articulated we really try to you so in
Composer we provide a list of key
features and those key features a
essential around three main schemes
simplicity security and production
monitoring our explaining each one in
turn so for simplicity we have
convenient tools like Cloud SDK or clock
console for you to interact and manage
composer services we also make it easy
for you to manage your workflow tags we
make it easy for you to manage plugins
and then moving on to the security bit
we use cloud I am to manage all the
credentials permissions and access
policies composer also comes together
works building support for cloud
identity or web proxy so that your
workflow monitoring web web server is
secured and protected and finally we
realize the we we also integrate with
stack driver to provide you with logging
and a magic mind monitoring metrics so
that you can build a dashboard to
visualize the internal state of your
work your workflows and also alert you
when your workflow is not running well
I'm going to discuss like a key concept
in cloud composer that's called
environment so what is a composer
environment there's nothing but more
than just a manager deployment of Apache
alpha inside a single GC
project you could have multiple
environments and those environments are
perfectly isolated from each other in
each environment we provides you with a
cloud storage while you can manage your
tax sources or your workflow sources and
you also have the stack we also provide
you an individual a workflow web servers
for you to access your workflow status
pertaining to that specific environment
finally we have stack driver that
provides convenient tools for you to
navigate through multiple environments
and last thing I want to mention that
each environment is protected by cloud I
am so you can config permissions
individually for each environment now
we're going to talk about some of the
design decisions earlier I mentioned
that a composer has open source in his
quarry and you know there are a lot of
open source orchestration solutions why
which cycle an apache alpha for those of
one for those of you who are not very
familiar with Apache outflow here's a
bit quick history on it it was
originally from IO PNB and that project
gets donated to Apache Software
Foundation at seeing in combination
stage incubation station now but soon to
graduate we choose a patch out flow for
a number of benefits number one it's
open source space on Python easy to use
it has a lot of wireless tablet
interface today you know you have web
server you have you has a very nice web
server
convenient command line tools it was as
an experimental API server for you to
interact with the service
programmatically one thing I want to
highlight for Apache outflow is that it
has a very powerful and flexible
scheduling at dependency mechanisms so
pretty much you're being code a lot of
different dependency relationships among
your tasks in a workflow it has a lot of
community contributed connectors for
example you know you have connectors to
aw as Google cloud platform interface to
a lot of database as well and last thing
is the Apache airflow community is very
active there are lots of commits many
developers fear is a it's overall is a
fairly active community on the tongue
side I think it's probably when the
project get started wasn't really
focused a lot on you know for example
like a production setup permission
management
logging debugging or a lot of stuff for
example you know we don't you know patch
out flow we don't really mandate say how
you want to run your web server how
would you scale your machines when they
will workload against more so those
happen to be the things that Google
cloud platform is good at so in cloud
composer we provide infrastructure
scalability we have security built in
with cloud IEP as well as cloud I am we
make it real easy for you to deploy tags
and we have select driver lock in the
monitoring if we were to make sure your
outflow environments running well I also
wanted to mention another point is that
we don't clock the Google doesn't intend
to just you know fork a copy of Apache
outflow and just you know make us
service ourselves we want to work
together with the community and together
enhance and improve Apache airflow so in
the past we have worked together with
the community to contribute the
equipment executed back to the airflow
community as I mentioned composer /l
flow comes together with a number of
built-in servicers I'm not going to read
out all the services some of the notable
ones are be a query GC as pops up
dataflow so you as a composer user you
don't have to worry about you know how
would I interact with those services
instead composer or L flow provides
provides nice operators for you to start
interacting with those services we
started worrying about authentication
and API details I'm also going to give
you a little bit of details on
architectures how we build a composer so
if you look at the overview of the
architecture it has two projects one is
the customer project the other one is
the titanum project so custom projects
really the things you see on a daily
basis when you're log into a cloud
console where you use class decay so
those are the projects owned by you and
you have full admin control over those
projects on the other side that's kind
of project panel projects again it's
also a Google cloud platform project but
those projects are owned by no service
in this case is the cloud composed
service
we decided to host some services in
Tainan project for enhanced security and
battery isolation
we'll come to that point in a minute in
this set up we try to given we try to
set up in a way that sort of like
reflects the popular elf flow plus city
executor config given the micro service
nature the framework of our flow our
implementation was also very reflex data
structure for example there will be an
outflow scheduler service that's an elf
the worker has also an outflow web
server
so our flow scheduler and air flow
worker we host both inside a kunai the
executor inside our kubernetes engines
in the customer project and then for our
flow web server as I mentioned we hosted
a web server in tenon project so we can
have integrated and building support for
cloud IP protection instead of
configuring IP yourself
club composer that's data for you and
you manage that access to your web
server using composer permissions in the
audition you probably have also noticed
that we have put a
outflowed database inside a tenon
project as well the reason behind is
that we believe since our flow stores
connection which is the access
credentials in our flow of database so
we want to make sure that that database
is only accessible to a very narrow set
of users with service accounts in our
default setup the outflow database is
only accessible to the service account
that you used to run the Qunari engine
by the way you could in you could what
during composer creation you have the
choice to specify which service account
you want to use to run your kubernetes
engine so let's move back to the
customer project we have reddy's which
is the city backend for broke for
messaging distribution and we have the
sequel proxy for accessing in the
database
moving down the graph a little bit we
see the tags plugins and locks they all
those photos are all created inside her
project poor environment Google Cloud
Storage bucket again composer manage the
distribution of the decks to your
various airflow services so you don't
have to worry about whether you know how
could you can how do you make sure your
outflow service gotta sync to the latest
tags
likewise for plugins in our flow the
plugins I for you to write customized
operators I here composer would also
take care of plugging integration into
your outflow services and finally at the
bottom of the life side of the website
bottom you see the logs the stack drive
logging in addition to our floor logs
the scheduler and worker logs are also
saved in stackdriver
we do that so that it provides a
centralized place for you to navigate
through all of locks but in addition
also try to make streaming logs really
fast and really on time for you
so he has a quick recap we have just
talked about what a composer is the
problems composer tries to solve some of
our product initial product goes the
site of fit the some of the composer
notable features and our design
decisions next we're going to talk about
how can we use composer to actually
author and schedule a workflow so to
create and access composer environments
there are three ways you could either
use you can use cloud SDK which is our
command line tool or you can you can use
the cloud console which the UI tool and
finally you can also interact with the
service programmatically using our API
there's no additional setup step you
need to do when people start to working
on start to working on workflows once
the composing environment is created the
next thing you need to do is to focus
your workflow development in the context
of Apache al flow it's also called dag
which stands for direct acyclic graph
what that means is in your workflow you
shouldn't really have cycles so here's a
quick example about you know how a
typical workflow with dag will look like
imagine that you have some files that is
hosted on Prem in HDFS and then
periodically you want to copy that file
say for example if you detect that new
files then you want to copy that files
to GCS bucket and once the data is
available in G says you may want to
launch a bigquery job and then try to
process the data and then you know get
some useful insights from the data and
once that insights is available you may
want to you know send out that data to a
stack slack channel so that could be
some of the typical workflow you'll be
run inside composer there are about five
steps really for you to write an offload
egg or workflow we summarized that into
four
steps import right arguments do your
deck setup lay down the various tasks
and in code past dependencies so this is
the standard part you know before you
write your deck or workflow you import
all the necessary libraries in this case
you want to make sure you import the
tags the operators from alpha and if you
have specific or customized trigger
rules you also want to import that from
L flow as well and once you have the
import in place you could start to
construct your arguments so our flow
comes out flow dag has a default tag
argument section which for you to
specify hello arguments that apply to
all tasks in a dag so for example you
can specify like when you want your tag
to get started what do you want to
receive email when there's a tag failure
and if a task fails how many times you
want to retry that task what's the delay
between consecutive which wives so this
ties back to my earlier to our earlier
discussion writing workflows yourself I
mean in this chrome Plus scripting
example you have to worry
all those retries yourself and you have
to actually building your own emails
email operator inside so that make sure
you get notification when attack or
workflow fails here being composer
waiting out flow you get all that being
provided for you already
the only thing you need to do is write
your configuration and leave all the
details to your composer without flow so
after that if you have additional global
variables that you plan to use in your
dag again you can list them here so for
example here we have you know the github
table we have the output file and the BQ
data set names after that you start to
set up set up your deck by giving a give
it a tiger name define an interval that
how often attack should be triggered and
execute it and then of course you pass
the d4 acts are you
to your dad that's one thing I want to
highlight here is that make sure that
your scheduled interval is set here you
can't set a schedule interval in addy
for eggs you only work there so that's
the one thing I want to point out when
you write your Dax
the next step is basically lay down all
the tasks you need in this workflow so
in this specific example we have two
tasks one is about running a bigquery
task
the other one is publishing the via
Korea output to GCS as you can imagine
you can have as many tasks as you want
our flow also allows you to
programmatically generate a task for
example you know write a use a full loop
to generate an array of tasks so all
these are entirely possible in a flow
and finally you specify the dependency
or orderings among your tasks in this
case where this line says I want to run
my big query first before I expose the
result to GCS which make a lot of sense
in this case once you have everything
together then you're good to go so now
we didn't give a live demo on using
composer so that we tie all the concepts
we have discussed
no back to the demo I to for the sake of
the presentation try to save some time I
have pre created to a composing
environment so if you click on one of
the environment I call it like in this
case it's called a composer demo there's
a number of pipes and then you could you
got to see all the details that pertain
to a specified composing environment I'm
going to quickly go over some of
properties don't worry if you can't read
out the text on the screen for example
you have an environment name you have a
location whether that's environment is
running us Central Europe West one you
got a chance to specify a service
account that's also a specified composer
version that you are running to in this
environment now some details related to
the worker note which we use to run our
flow scheduler and out flow workers like
in machine type the disk size and etc
there are two things that you will want
to pay you want to pay special attention
why it's called Dax folder so if we
click through that Dax folder like this
you to a place where all the X should be
staged to deploy a dag is as simple as
like a drop a file in your stack folder
text folder and likewise you realize
that there's another one that's called
ion flow web UI if you click that web UI
that leads you to the familiar outflow
web UI interface you get all day you
will be able to access all workflow
related information as well as some of
the configuration and their admin panel
in order to access this L flow web
server you need to make sure that you
have the right permission so I escaped
the party since I have re-logging you
probably won't prompt me for logging but
if you're going to create one yourself
and try it offline you probably will see
a login window propping you for email
and password so that's the way how cloud
IEP works it checks for your
you checks that the user has a read
permission before it allows you to open
the outflow web UI so as I mentioned
deploying a dag it's as simple as
dropping a file here so that let me get
that started so I'm going to upload a
dag file this Dyke file in fact it's
called QuickStart is the in fact the
QuickStart guide in our documentation
website so I'll just upload this one
it's done it takes a few minutes for
outflow to pick up the bag and start
execution while waiting for outflow to
pick up the tags and then I want to also
want to give you a some quick overview
on some of the other configuration
you're going to be able to do in cloud a
composer we allows you to update our
flow configuration in real time so for
example if you want to hide the
configuration in the admin panel
you could add you could just you know
make a change to say hey web server
expose configure to false that after
that change your configuration will be
hidden from view or formed a login the
users we also allows you to install pi
PI dependencies imagine that your
workflow requires say slight clients to
be installed will sign PI to be
installed you could simply just you know
use the pi PI package management feature
in composer and then specify the
packages you want to install so for
example you could add a package you
could add a slight client and then you
can also specify an optional version
string so that's all you need to do
update clears click Submit that's all
you need to do to get the dependency in
store for you now let's come back to the
outflow web UI let's do a refresh
because our flow web server doesn't do
refresh by itself there we go we see the
quick start start to appear in in a web
UI there because as we mentioned earlier
our flow as a micro service like
so you have a web server component it
also has a scheduler component notes
component and not perfectly sync so
sometimes if you say things like bags
being recognized in one place but not
the other place just give it a few more
minutes and we'll just do a few more
refreshes and hopefully we'll see that
that's being shown soon there we go
so click through the tags this is the it
has different views for you to navigate
through your tag structure that's a
graphic view so that you see that they
have we have three tasks like create a
data product class stir run a simple
what kind of example and then delete the
data product cluster that's different
views like graph view tree view and you
will also be able to see the details for
example like how long does it take for a
particular task to complete in many
cases if you want to inspect the code
you could also see the code here so
let's go back to the web UI right now we
are in a stage of trying to create a
data product cluster so we can go to
viola logs
see what has been done what has been
specified there this essentially says
hey right now this task has started some
of you may wonder like given the airflow
already has us you know workflow what
task logs why you still want to provide
work logs or logs in stackdriver here's
one difference if you go to stack driver
logging
go to compose a demo and then go to
outflow workers you actually see a lot
of more things here
the reason between set differently
I'll float wives to upload logs
periodically so whenever it comes
together with every you know depends on
some internal costs so you don't always
see the lady's logs but with stackdriver
logging in composer you will be able to
see all the logs that happening in real
time
sometimes if you happen to have a task
that takes a while to complete let's say
a few minutes wait in some extreme case
maybe an hour to finish and this you
want to be able to see those blocks
earlier so stagger blocks would be the
place while you could see all the
streaming logs let's go back as we can
see the first tag the creator product
class the task is done now we move to
the what counts tasks one thing you
notice that you know our flow was as a
UI to highlight the different stage of
the task for example you know you you
get a dark green when the task is done
and relative light green when the task
is still active I will give you a few
more minutes to let the work flow to
complete but as you can see once the
plastics done you will be able to see a
lot more details in a lock so those
contains all the logs that immediate by
Al flow this the I want to say that
looks locks are very helpful sometimes
when you have a task failure you have no
idea what's happening those locks
provides you know the initial place for
you to do investigation a lot of times
the failures or exceptions were belong
here you could also view there are other
views for you to manage your tasks they
provide a task views which you see pass
from all workflows running in this club
in this environment you would also be
able to see the active die grunts so you
have that view task view it depends on
your need there's very flexible for you
to navigate through your work
clothes sometimes you can also create a
manual run in case for example if you
don't want to wait until you're certain
and if you don't want to wait and hear
the scheduled interval it is also
possible for you to just create a for
you to create a manual run yourself just
kidding
put a dag ID give it a run ID and then
click save that it will start a manual
run after same workflow now we have seen
that all the tasks has been successfully
completed and then you also have the sum
of the stats here as well like how long
does it take for it has to complete yep
so that that's the end of the demo we're
going to switch back to the slides
so here's a quick recap on a demo we
just lost really like we just showed you
how to escape it a part of creating
composing environments there's a reason
why I'm gonna discuss that and also give
you different ways in this case we
primarily focus on cloud console for you
to access the composing environment but
it is also possible to interact with
composer environment using cloud SDK or
like even an API next we shown you how
to upload a dag at simply I just drag
and drop a file into the GCS Baghead and
then we have worked you through the
various UI features comes together with
Apache airflow web server and finally we
also talked about why we want to use
stackdriver some to exam composer logs
so you don't have to wait until the task
is done so you can see streaming logs
coming in as the task executes I'm going
to wrap up the webinar by saying you
know some giving you some pointers to
get you started
given composer as a manager patch
outflow service so all Apache outflow
concepts would apply in composer we
recommend you to go over the Apache
outflow documentation and also some of
the start guide there they have very
good documentation explaining the
concepts of tags they also give you a
lava tubes tutorials as well
specifically on the clock composer
documentation website I also give you
all the details about how would you
interact with the composer environment
helps you create an environment helps
you manage your environment and helps
you access your environment in addition
also give you like pricing information
how was your morning - your composing
environment how to interact with
stackdriver
overflows excuse me how to interact with
stackdriver logging in the monitoring
and finally the team is trying to add
more bag examples in composer so we have
some pre we have a few examples in the
github that the team plan to add more
there
so that will be the end of the of the
presentation staying tuned for the live
Q&A will be back in a few minutes
you
welcome back to the Q&A session so I'm
getting rid outta questions post Leah
here so the first question is about how
long does it take to create in my
composing environment we have received
some customer feedback saying hey seems
take a long time for me to create my
composing environment sometimes can be
like it can be 15 or even 20 minutes
the reason here is that together with
composer we also host the ion flow web
server inside a Google App Engine and
for those of you who have used Google
App Engine in the past you probably know
that it takes about 15 minutes to get
your App Engine app created initialized
and stabilized so that's the reason why
creating composing environment takes 15
to 20 minutes now the the second
question is about how do I get email
notifications when the workflow fails if
you still recall in when we work through
the tag structure in one section that's
a configuration option in default acts
section while you can say hey email on
failure or receive email notification
you also need to put that by the way you
also need to put an email address there
so given there some limitation in Google
cloud platform mainly from spam and
security perspective that you can use
SMTP directly when running application
in gke so instead we use in this case we
use centigrade for all email
notifications to config settings to
configure email for using in centigrade
service really you only need to supply
an email and send great API key as well
as a form address and then those can be
configured as part of your composer
environment variables our documentation
website has a lot of more details about
how would you be able what kind of
environment variables should be put into
your composing environment to get an
email working for you
the next question is about which Apache
outflow versions does composer support
that's a very good
so right now composure only supports
like alpha 1.9 we it's on our roadmap to
support multiple versions of had shell
flow so for example at environment
creation time you could specify hey I
want to use alpha 1.8 or one point one
point
well flow one point 10 so those are its
those multi-version support is on our
roadmap for sure but right now only 1.9
support the next question is do you have
any suggestion on migrating unprimed
l flow set up to composer so ideally
given composer as a manager patch L flow
solution your dad should work
transparently cross on pram and the GCP
and vice versa sometimes we do notice
that you know if your dad's has
referenced local environment for example
if you try to access report to local
file systems or other sort of none
non-standard out flow operators those
those won't be might be a friction for
you so you want to make sure those get
corrected and then if you make sure that
your workflows doesn't refer to anything
in your local environments then in
addition of copying your tags from your
M Prime to composer the other thing you
need to concern will be the outflow
database migration if it's the same
outflow version the migration can be as
easy as experts export your database
data and then import that again in
composer or you can if you don't want to
retain all the history you could also
selectively just copy over the
configuration the connections or
variable configurations you need next
question is can I orchestrate a hybrid
environment with composer yes
that's totally possible so you could
have task of running on prime as long as
you make sure that for example there's a
network you know you have the right
network connection setup in place
composure or outflow is really agnostic
to the type of task let's gas execute it
the next question is very similar can i
orchestrate a multicolor environment
with composing yes as I mentioned
earlier they are connectors to not only
to GCP but they are also connectors to
AWS or agile or other cloud providers
including Apache airflow so really the
only thing you need to do here is to
make sure you have the credentials
config as the as connections in airflow
or composer and afterwards when you try
to instantiate an operator to another
cloud provider make sure you refer to
the right connection name string so
that's all you need to do the last
question is about oh I have a lot of
tasks in my workflow
how does composer a hand or outflow
worker scaling very good question for
now we do the composer API service that
allows you to manually scale the number
of workers so for example if you realize
that Oh suddenly you have you have a you
have a burst of tasks with which where
you need to stand maybe a thousand tasks
and what your machines running short of
machinery source what you need to do is
just log into the console we'll use
class 2k to upsize the number of worker
nodes you have will automatically manage
the the scanning for you as well as
making sure that our flow configurations
are updated accordingly to match your
cluster size you know notably in there
are few scalability or parallelism
configuration options related to a
number of workers you could have so
those will be taking care of by composer
so you don't have to worry about that at
all in addition although scaling is also
our facial roadmap so we may have Auto
skinning support some time as a result
you don't have to worry about skinning
at all
so that will be the end of the Q&A
session Thank You thanks a lot for
staying to listen to the webinar and
definitely stay in tune for next
Tuesday's webinars